[Music]
run what are you doing
frun
[Music]
Mr
snow after everything you've seen out
there in the
world what are the Hunger Games for
are
[Music]
are the Hunger Games they to punish the
districts those tributes don't have a
choice Your Role is to turn these
children into spectacles not
survivors we're
live smile it's why we have teeth
imagine it was your name that they
pulled it
strange I just want to know that
somebody still cared about me that I was
still of
value welcome to the capital you look
like you shouldn't be here I shouldn't
but I'm your Mentor a
rebel I am going to get you out of here
you want to protect
people then it's essential to accept
what human beings
are and what it takes to control them
let's see you use that famous snow
charm you seem like a good man Corina
snow I have seen what war does to
people filled with the turve becoming
prey see how quickly we become
Predator I want my enemies to see a
rainbow of
Destruction engulfing the
world
your monsters all of
you good luck with that poor little song
bird where is
she it's mystery and Mysteries have a
way of driving people
mad Mr snow let me ask you one final
time what are the Hunger Games for
a
Hanging
[Music]
Tree it's the things we love most that
destroy
[Music]
us